[Music]
DC Comics what totally just dangling on
a still rope absolutely zero security at
Wayne Manor nipple bed East Alfred tells
you how the movie will end 17 minutes
and Blake knows exactly where to go to
find Gordon Blake knows Wayne his Batman
because of a look on his face doesn't
use Batman voice in hospital even though
he's wearing a mask cop should be able
to trace a cell phone without a call
being made Batman gets pickpocket
magical Robo knee brace
Alfred suddenly knows everything about
Bay where the hell did the motorcycles
come from daytime when they go in the
tunnel nighttime when they come out we
set a Galaxy Note well it's Batman's
Galaxy Note now ridiculous clean slate
concept this guy falls down for no
reason he uses Batman boys to talk to
himself
Alfred wines like a little bitch and
breaks up with Batman illegal stock
market trades made during an armed
takeover are allowed to stand oh snap
better trust this we know nothing about
what Bane tickles a man to death pop
scramble this doorway wait is she
actually surprised that Wayne is Batman
Bane hits air for Batman goes down this
is not Batman this is a Batman costume
Bane knows exactly where the R&D lab is
even though it's off the books
so Bane flew halfway around the world to
the prison hole just to taunt Wayne only
to fly back to Gotham what a woman in a
men's prison justified by a cartwheel
every available cop sent down to the
sewers at once doctor turns reactor into
nuke in two minutes flat police officer
just now realizing that guns kill
Gotham football team draws fewer fans
than Jacksonville Hines Ward shows
acting range by returning kickoffs Blake
says screw it guns are good again why
didn't they just blow up this bridge
like the others
US government does basically nothing to
help Gotham if this were the Avengers
we'd have nuke the city just to kill
Bink Bane doesn't Adam Sandler
impression
why is being keeping the police alive
and that folks is the basis of
chiropractic medicine liam neeson isn't
killing anyone in the scene Bruce gets
crucial plot details from his own
hallucinations wait is Catwoman a
lesbian this wall actually still looks
pretty easy to get over the prison hall
halfway around the world gets better
cable reception than I do
that fall alone would kill these guys
are terrible at hiding
Bruce destroys his only way of knowing
what's going on in Gotham would you just
climb out of the pit already sudden
stupid bad omen did he teleport it to
the city eventual bad guy hopes good
guys find the bomb he's the street
artist that Gotham deserves but not the
one it needs right now
also Christopher Nolan just ripped off
the crow another guy falls down for no
reason count to five then throw one two
three
dude she knows you're Bruce Wayne you
can chill out with the voice cops with
batons charge machine guns and tanks and
most don't gun remember how his back is
broken and his knee has no cartilage
plot twists turns Bane into a lovesick
puppy dog Catwoman surprise save the day
surprises no one would it kill you for
once to just say I'm Bruce Wayne and
stop being so cryptic this nuke with the
six mile blast radius would definitely
have incinerated Batman we didn't die in
the blast but the radiation will
certainly kill us hooray
oh yeah Alfred's in this movie isn't
this the same ending as the postman
Robin Oh give me a break no one notices
the most famous recently dead person in
the world sitting at this cafe
[Music]
some men just want to watch the world
burn in the shape of a bat drawn with
gasoline